so what's being done to resolve this
massive global issue well there are
people trying to do that nest so a lot
of small little local charities working
in their communities across Ethiopia
cameroon or ghana and these are
generally women's charities looking at
empowerment and women some of the larger
charities are also working on this and
doing again what they can to have an
impact on communities and certainly
bodies like UNICEF do have strategies
have come up with their ideas for
solutions so it's not just being ignored
this is the UNICEF coordinated strategy
to abandon FGM in one generation this is
what the UN is saying it can do we can
eliminate it we can abandon it in one
generation but we're not this has been
studied to death and what we need to do
now is get on and do some implementation
eliminating FGM this is a statement that
goes across all of the UN agencies all
saying they're committed to eliminating
it what we need is a global push to
commit to these three million girls and
say enough is enough we've done the
strategies we've done the talking now
we're going to do something
you